vous êtes très proche de vos fans moi je
me rappelle de la vidéo vous aviez fait
monter à un fan sur scène c'était
exceptionnel
ouais tellement proches que vous avez
voulu vous immiscer dans un groupe vous
les avez piégée ouais ça c'est une idée
de holly aussi c'est et olic est tous
des idées aux armes oui je suis un peu
créatif du des hollies et ses fans en
fait ils pensaient être interviewé voilà
sur vous ouais ils pensaient qu'ils
allaient passer l'émission et nous on
était déguisé en étaient cachés derrière
les cadors de la perche trop derrière la
gamme des produits hard et regardez la
réaction c'est énorme mais elle est
folle cette réaction regardez ils ont
piégé leurs fans
[Musique]
tu es fan de vie tchô au lit mes
chansons préférées c'est avec papa et
est rentré chez vous c'est quoi ce que
tu as une chaise ou j'aime bien parce
qu'ils sont vraiment proches des phones
c'est une super attachant et généreux
avec les fans jésus sur les réseaux et
ils sont sans moi je les trouve géniaux
et est ce que tu es déjà les voir en
concert
non parce que j'ai pas eu l'occasion moi
je suis allé au zénith de paris au
zénith de rang et un concert nrj gratuit
à quantième s'il était en face de toi tu
aimerais leur dire quoi
ba qui continue comme ça que j'aimerais
bien les voir en concert baby cloué au
lit ça rime avec bravo et merci et c'est
quelque chose que j'ai toujours pensé
c'est bon c'est très gentil tu dis ça
vraiment super niveau je suis perdu il
avait vu en rêve non
oui ça tu vois franchement sa maman
[Musique]
c'est la famille gros bisous je les
monte six épreuves
on va prendre vos noms vous venez au
concert très bon mathieu questions de
journalistes quand vous êtes en tournée
s quel hôtel dans les mêmes chambres et
si vous n'êtes pas dans la même chambre
sk maintenant souvent des petits et pour
quels médias mais pas du tout mais parce
que je vois que les fans mais monsieur
pleure devant vous ce qui est fascinant
et bref ça vous touche et ça franchement
ça arrive pas mais bien parce que figure
toi qu'on a on est un tour bus et oui et
quand on part à chaque fois à la fin des
concerts on dort pas dans des hôtels on
est entouré bus et on est 18 dans le
tour bus donc c'est pas trop l'ambiance
ouais d'accord n'a pas ramené de ma faim
mode salut les gars ils sont pas comme
ça ce couple souvenez votre première sur
le plateau de touche pas à mon poste et
on avait essayé le faux battle non c'est
en croit que ma vie' que la chine oui
c'était sale [ __ ] un hall il avait
ensuite avec ta tête barétous je me suis
exactement ténors en année c'était avant
la coupure pub ça avait fait le buzz sur
twitter les gens savaient pas c'était
vrai ou faux regardez savez vous savez
je me suis dit que ça cartonnait jeff
pas la côte d'ivoire voilà il fallait
donc sérieux battu les guignols a depuis
thaler savait mais lente à un singe
carrément c'est ça tiens il ya plus
twitter lors la terre frites et d'avril
enfin bon ce n'est pas heureux parce que
je ne vous ai jamais appliqué dans
touche pas à mon poste exact et bien
allez-y
dites ce que vous avez à dire on vous
écoute maintenant ça c'est beau non
ayant mec j'ai trop faim depuis qu'on
est dans le public
je vais prendre un kebab sens blanche
avec des frites longue du trompe c'est
pas le vendeur de kebabs mais c'est le
présentateur c'est lui alors la paix
shirine le plus grand des acteurs mais
les pas perdus fava grand chose j'te
ferai pas de flair même site à la tête
d'un vendeur de roses à des tuteurs télé
était partout c'est fatigant pour faire
tout ça tu engagé quoi associe du
pakistan n'ont fait vrai qu'on arrête
parce que comme tout le monde en garde
les missions le soir en cacher vernet
des mythos est parce qu on est juste des
poteaux les personnes nous croient chez
nous cyril on peut prendre une photo
[Applaudissements]